[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy el programa
feminista de frases 24 cada 25 de
noviembre se conmemora el Día
Internacional de la eliminación de la
violencia de género un objetivo que a la
fecha es una utopía pero seguimos
trabajando por alcanzarlo en el mundo al
menos una de cada tres mujeres se ve
afectada por algún tipo de violencia de
género y cada 11 minutos una mujer o
Niña muere asesinada por un familiar la
ONU señala que necesitamos prevenir y
responder a las violencias La Brecha de
género nos impide el desarrollo
sostenible y evita que todas tengamos el
acceso a una vida digna
sobre esta fecha particular en la que el
activismo es si debe ser el protagonista
vamos a conversar con Verónica Vera ella
es directora ejecutiva de la
organización feminista surcuna en
Ecuador surcona además trabaja para que
las mujeres las adolescentes y las niñas
puedan ejercer sus derechos sexuales y
reproductivos vivir una vida libre de
violencias y acceder a la justicia y a
la reparación decidiendo sobre sus
cuerpos y sus vidas dicho esto Verónica
gracias a usted por prestarnos su uso
para hablar de violencia de género que
nos afecta a todas todos los días
Muchas gracias a ti por la invitación
estoy muy agradecida de estar acá y
gustosa también de que el 25 podamos
hablar de este tema que es un tema que
nos atraviesa el cuerpo la vida todos
los días no los feminicidios y la
violencia en nuestra cuenta sobre eso
quiero empezar quiero pedirle que
hablemos sobre feminicidio un crimen en
aumento frecuentemente mal tipificado y
además mal informado en América Latina
porque las cifras alarmantes en los
países de esta región Y por qué tenemos
que prestar más atención al tema
bueno es importante decir que el
feminicidio en la mayoría de países no
es santificado que lo que suele estar
tipificado del femicidio es decir la
muerte de una mujer por el hecho de ser
mujer y lo que se reconoce en la mayoría
de leyes es la responsabilidad de los
agresores sin embargo estos feminicidios
suceden en un contexto de total
impunidad social no donde la sociedad
sigue justificando la violencia en donde
seguimos culpabilizando a las víctimas
en donde le decimos una víctima que
busca protección o busca poner una
denuncia que no denuncia que su esposo
que su pareja que le va a hacer daño no
entonces hay un contexto social hay un
contexto Estatal que no logra prevenir
que estos hechos violentos ustedes por
ejemplo en Ecuador que es de donde yo
vengo este año 2022 ha sido el año más
violento
durante todos estos años que se ha
tipificado el femicidio que ellos son
más de cinco o seis años entonces lo que
quiere decir que el femicidio también
responde a los contextos sociales que
estamos viviendo desde una violencia
extrema contra las mujeres pero que
responde también a los contextos de
mayor pobreza de mayor precarización de
menos de inversión social en donde hay
menores condiciones de vida dignas donde
las mujeres vivimos más violencias de
género en fin que volvemos al mismo
punto de origen y es la brecha de género
la desigualdad entre hombres y mujeres y
las mujeres aún siendo tratadas como
ciudadanas de segunda clase y a veces ni
siquiera eso Ahora hay que dejarlo muy
claro nos están matando pero aún cuando
no se llega a esta que es la culminación
de los ciclos de violencia siguen
existiendo estas violaciones constantes
y además es lo más grave todavía
normalizadas Cuáles son para usted esas
violencias más comunes a las que
deberíamos prestar más atención para no
llegar a extremos como el feminicidio
por ejemplo
bueno diría que ninguna violencia es más
o menos importante no se quedó otra más
o menos relevante eso es lo primero que
tenemos que reconocer O sea que si una
mujer está viviendo violencia
psicológica que es por ejemplo la más
común de las violencias en el mundo no
es por donde empieza el ciclo de
violencia en donde empieza la
manipulación en donde empiezan a hacerte
sentir de menos en donde empiezan a
decir que no vales la pena no Y eso es
lo que permite que efectivamente luego
se ejerza quizás violencia física
violencia sexual Entonces es súper
relevante que como sociedad escuchemos
los llamados de auxilio por ejemplo de
las mujeres que tenemos a nuestro lado
Si vemos que hay una relación de poderse
hay relaciones de manipulación que
podamos acercarnos de manera
cercana cuidadosa también a las mujeres
que nos rodean a nuestras amigas a
nuestras madres a nuestras hermanas y
decirles mira lo que tú estás viviendo
no es normal tú no eres menos tú no eres
una persona que debe dejarse manipular
intentar acercarnos pero finalmente si
no logramos de su cercanía creo que
debemos de estar dispuestas apoyar para
que esta mujer busque ayuda cuando esté
lista para hacerlo no y escuchar todas
las señales no culpabilizarnos a
nosotras mismas de la violencia la
violencia que vivimos jamás Disculpa de
las víctimas y de hecho creo que como
pusiera también debemos dejar de
normalizar el acoso sexual en las calles
por ejemplo el acoso callejero que es
algo que se siente que no pasa nada que
solo es la cosa que solo es algo pequeño
pero que en realidad repercute en otras
formas de violencia y en que vivamos en
una sociedad en donde no nos sentimos
protegidas ni cuidadas está claro que el
mundo en general no es un lugar seguro
para nacer mujer todos los días las
niñas son violentadas desde que nacemos
se nos asignan roles de género que nos
afectan a lo largo de nuestra vida y nos
hacen más vulnerables a las violencias
de género Cuáles son esos roles que
Proponen ustedes que eliminemos para
protegernos desde que somos niñas y
tengamos un en un mundo ideal y utópico
une libre desarrollo y una vida en la
que podamos tener herramientas para
hablar por nosotros
bueno para empezar efectivamente
necesitamos vivir en contextos en un
mundo en donde las tareas del cuidado
sean repartidas de manera más equitativa
en este mundo las mujeres nos hacemos
cargo tres veces más del cuidado del
hogar por ejemplo del cuidado de la
familia del cuidado de los hijos que los
hombres entonces a partir de que hayan
cuidado en donde los hombres puedan ser
corresponsables de lo que suceden las
familias de que lo que sucede con los
niños con las niñas es importante Por
otra parte algo que es importante es que
las mujeres las niñas y las adolescentes
en la mayoría de países de latinoamérica
seguimos siendo criminalizadas y
judicializadas por tomar decisiones
sobre nuestro propio cuerpo y eso no
sucede en el caso de los hombres no el
aborto y las leyes que penalizan el
aborto afectan de manera
específica y concreta a las mujeres a
las niñas y a las adolescentes entonces
hay que romper también con estas
legislaciones que nos impiden tomar
decisiones libres sobre nuestra
sexualidad y nuestra reproducción y
finalmente yo diría que también en algo
que es importante es como sacar de
nuestra cabeza este esta idea de que el
amor Todo lo puede de que el amor Todo
lo soporta no que nos meten en la cabeza
y que el amor es es eso no es vivir
soportar aguantar para nada del amor Es
sentirse en un espacio cuidada Segura
que no tengas miedo no Y si sientes
Miedo cuestionarte por qué Porque
sientes de ese miedo no el amor no es
aguantar todo No es quedarse El amor es
efectivamente primero por una misma y
también por dejar Estos espacios donde
nos sentimos con miedo e incómoda y
además el amor Debería ser sano y en
condiciones de igualdad no cuando se
habla específicamente de estas
relaciones de pareja hablemos un poco
sobre eso porque la violencia de género
empieza cuando hay relaciones de poder
cuando hay una persona que se siente con
poder para abusar sobre otra persona y
también nos han vendido y de eso la
culpa es en gran parte de nosotros
medios de comunicación que los o los
violentos Son psicópatas son enfermos
mentales es decir en cierta manera se
excusa a esta persona violenta como
derribamos ese mito y combatimos la
realidad de triste y dura pero es que
estamos criando matones y estamos
creando violadores esto viene desde
desde nuestras propias raíces
exactamente primero creo que lo que hay
que asumir es que hemos fallado como
sociedad en la educación de las niñas y
los niños no entonces hay que apostarle
para que la educación que reciben sea
una educación en derechos humanos que
fomenta la igualdad que fomente la
equidad en las relaciones que fomente el
respeto y que de alguna manera rompes
esos roles de género que veníamos de
hablando y lo segundo creo yo es que
efectivamente hay que reconocer que los
agresores sexuales los feminicidas son
hombres comunes y corrientes o sea es
del vecino que nos caía bien al que le
saludamos es No pues era a veces alguien
de nuestra familia no es del tío que era
súper simpático que en las cenas de
Navidad
nos daciera reír a todos O sea hay que
desmitificar que los agresores sexuales
que los feminicidas son hombres lejanos
más bien hay que saber que están en
nuestro entorno y hay que tener los ojos
muy abiertos para responder a los
llamados de auxilio por ejemplo que
hacen los niños las niñas Los
Adolescentes cuando están viviendo
sexual que lamentablemente en el mundo
sucede especialmente en sus familias en
sus entornos de cuidado en sus círculos
cercanos Entonces yo diría que como
sociedad Ahora nos quiere estar atentas
estar vigilantes y creerles a los niños
a las niñas a las adolescentes y a las
mujeres cuando dicen que algo no les
hace bien cuando dicen que están
viviendo algo que no les gusta que les
incomoda cuando dicen que el tío que el
abuelito que el primo les hace sentir
mal entonces creo que como sociedad
nuestro rol está ahorita en proteger
cuidar creer y sobre todo transformar la
educación creo que eso será más a largo
plazo pero tenemos que transformar la
educación
empieza a acabar el tiempo pero no
quería dejarla ir sin hablar acerca de
las víctimas No ese machismo que tenemos
tan interiorizado todos como sociedad no
nos permite o nos enseña que a las
víctimas no se les cree todavía hoy en
día seguimos culpando a las mujeres
cuando son Víctimas de violencia en vez
de culpar a los violentos
Por qué debemos a las víctimas hablemos
de ese principio fundamental
bueno efectivamente cuando una mujer
decide hablar de la violencia que está
viviendo es un grito de auxilio para
empezar y es un momento especialmente en
donde ella está en riesgo no porque está
decidiendo romper con el círculo de
violencia que ha venido viviendo
entonces de hecho en Ecuador por ejemplo
los feminicidios suceden la mayoría de
veces cuando la mujer ha decidido poner
una denuncia o ha decidido buscar ayuda
porque el agresor siente que deja de
tener poder sobre ella y se siente más
amenazado Y es ahí cuando ejerce la
violencia más de extrema entonces
justamente como sociedad como familias
tenemos que creer en las víctimas creer
en las mujeres que nos rodean porque
podemos ser entes de protección o sea
podemos convertirnos en círculos de
cuidados para esas mujeres cuando
deciden denunciar Entonces eso es lo que
podría decir que si no creemos en ellas
también podemos hacer que los
feminicidios de alguna forma tengan como
un contexto social en donde puedan
suceder y donde estén más legislados
entonces sería ese como mi consejo Igual
cuando sucedan agresiones contra niños
niñas adolescentes los niños niñas
quizás no nombran que están viviendo
violencia sexual o violación podrían
nombrar de otras formas como incomodidad
no me gusta que me toque el rechazo a
veces con una persona entonces creerles
escucharles buscar ayuda profesional si
no sentimos que tengamos dos
herramientas para dar una respuesta pues
Mire yo le doy una gran agradecimiento a
ustedes Verónica y a la organización
feminista surkuna por apoyarnos con
conceptos que a veces a veces parecen
tan básicos pero que nos faltan tanto en
la conversación diaria Muchas gracias a
usted y cierro con una de mis frases
favoritas para estas fechas de
conmemoración Y es que vivas nos
queremos Gracias también a nuestros
televidentes por estar con nosotros en
ella soy y nos vemos Próximamente en
France 24
[Música]